okay today's number is 383 laughs and I
know if the number of people have been
demanding no one has been demanding 383
this is one because another file has you
know grown over the years and you've
done all sorts of exciting numbers a PI
like all that all the big guys have been
involved but and I feel like we're with
we're losing touch with our roots like
we're not literal roots but like
metaphorical the simple numbers which
made this channel what it was and I
think 383 is not an amazing number it's
not a special numbers not a great number
but we can't forget about the the
numbers that are there day-in day-out
making math work focus the workhorses of
the number system 383 is a prime believe
me it's already amazing rabbit a lot of
primes it's also a palindrome I'm going
to write down some of these Hannah
palindrome how they spell it correctly
which is quite nice it is the sum of the
first three palindromic three-digit
primes and so if you get the first three
I think it's a hundred and one is a
three-digit palindrome plus 131
three-digit palindromic prime plus 151
is the next one that's the first three
of them that it was 383 that's kind of
cool there's something going on that
you're not doing a very good job making
me think this isn't a special number or
this is the great thing about numbers
there any any semi arbitrary number if
you dig into it it's going to have some
cool properties it's also the smallest
number which is the sum of a prime and
the reversal of the prime 241 is a prime
number and if you add it to its digit in
reverse order 1 4 2 equals 3 8 3 which
is itself prime so it's the smallest
number which is prime and it's a prime
number plus the reversal of the digits
of that prime number in base 10 that's
kind of cool that's a thing it's a bit
based any in fact anything involving
palindromes is with a base cannibal but
what are you going to do it's also a
thing called a will prime and a would or
prime let's set so good against a
different color a would all prime is a
prime number so Mersenne Prime's we're
we all know and love Mersenne Prime 2 to
the N minus 1 a wood or prime is n times
2 to the n plus 1 this is a wood or
prime it's a third wood all prime it is
6 times 2 to the 6 minus 1 equals 380
make sure of mind link 3 and so on to
name three - 83 I've been I've been
doing a lot of today radio as you know
and the fact is I know that the
palindrome I'd written over half of it
so I've got no excuses
so anyway right so wood wood all primes
again an unsung type of Prime and P
please go online we've done so many
views about Mersenne Prime's may send
numbers to Mersenne prime the base M
prime Mersenne prime don't get me wrong
big fan the wood all primes have you
ever heard them mentioned I mean I never
hear the mention I think they're great
and we do videos whenever we find a new
Mersenne prime because it's a big one
everyone celebrates miss Ambrose we did
a video when I printed it out it was
possibly over the top would all Prime's
G only the last time we had a new wood
or prime C no one does right and yet we
are still trying to find them so quick
bit of history they were first named or
used by a wood all in fact it was two
guys it was Cunningham in wood hall in
1917 which you will notice is exactly
100 years ago and so this is the
centenary we're in the centenary year of
wood all primes and I imagine I mean a
lot of people may be organizing wood all
prime parties but I haven't been invited
and I haven't heard about them mat if it
was one going on you would be well I
better be I'd be a little offended if I
wasn't and so I think in the centenary
year of wood all primes we should
celebrate the less significant the less
exciting the less well known types of
numbers as though 383 as a wood or prime
I think which we celebrating it in 1917
and what we can do other than having
parties if you want to celebrate it is
to help us find another one the last
time we found a world record wood all
prime was in 2007 so the last one we
found with in the 90th anniversary of
wood all primes wouldn't it be great to
find another one
the 100 year anniversary in case you're
wondering the last one we found the
world record it is three million seven
hundred and fifty two thousand nine
hundred and forty eight gets that right
times two to three million seven hundred
and fifty two thousand nine hundred and
forty eight minus one that's a prime
number and it has over a million it's
got 1 million one hundred twenty-nine
thousand seven hundred and fifty seven
digits that is a lot that is the current
biggest known would all prime so I think
we should try and find a better one that
was found not by the great internet
Mersenne prime search because in their
name as you can tell they're all that
Mersenne numbers they have no respect
they don't give any attention to the
smaller types of primes
there is another organized organization
called prime grid and prime grid deal
with all the other primes that the
Mersenne guys forgot about so people are
running very similar thing you can
download a thing you run it on your
computer your computer will check bigger
and bigger would all numbers to see if
any of them are prime if enough could
not many people do prime Grit I mean I
do as I speak there's a computer in my
office that I built solely to run prime
grid to try and find the I'm coming here
to try and find these out and they do
loads of other types of prime numbers
you can let your computer in this
downtime help us celebrate in the 100
year anniversary some unsung prime
numbers
thank you for watching this video and
thank you to Squarespace for supporting
us I use Squarespace almost every day
and I'd like to tell you why basically
it makes my life easier both for
business and creatively there's no fuss
it's quick and it makes my website to
look better than anything I could do on
my own
they have award-winning templates to get
you started and they're fantastic from
the word go but if you're one of those
people that likes to tweak things you do
have some freedom to do some
customization as well so whatever your
next move on the web is you really
couldn't do better than have everything
in one place from the domain to the
website building and you'll find all of
it at Squarespace if you need a
definition of all-in-one a one-stop shop
but with 24/7 customer support if you
need a helping hand
I already have three projects running on
Squarespace with more in the works and
you can check them out
at squarespace.com slash numberphile
that'll make sure they know you came
from here which helps us out
there's 10% of your first order using
the URL squarespace.com slash
numberphile and you can use the code
numberphile on check out that's for 10%
off and now thanks to Squarespace for
supporting this video
mostly number two get a little glory
partly because they're linked to perfect
numbers in fact that's why we cared
about them in the first place and now
it's because they're easy and they hold
I think they've either got all or 9 out
of 10 of the top 10 biggest primes or
almost and price because they're easy to
find right and so people check people to
go for glory all they care about are the
biggest one they go and pick off the
Mersenne primes whereas these other ones
they're not easy to find right and then
they know this is about well this is
well below right this is an order of
magnitude fewer digits than the current
world record Mersenne Prime and I think
it's a shame that we knew size isn't
everything we should be looking for
these other interesting numbers